Right now it's like Ghostbusters and. And then they made Charlie's angels,
which is, you know, women and a bomb.
[Inaudible].
I can tell when a movie is going to bomb, dude,
I can't wait until that cats movie comes out, bro.
I can't wait until that cats movie comes out.
That casting of the cats movie is
the most atrocious casting of all time, dude.
It's hilarious. And by the way, good actors in that movie.
Just the way it's cast and how put together it is, bro.
It's such a like Jason is in it.
Imagine he's in it. And he's just like, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
That song. Boo.
Wiggle wiggle with it poopoo. And he just goes Meow. Boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop. Around wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Oh, good comes with that big fat cat, but boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop dude. Jason Durham.
How much? I don't know if this is true or not,
but if Jay but Jason Derulo, his whole life is a Sprite commercial.
I don't give a dude. I can just imagine him just going like boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop. The fact that Jason Derulo, isn't it.
You know what? He's in his programmers. I don't give a.
He's gotta be in the Sprite numbers. If he's not in Sprite, commercial,
he's in the Sprite commercial. Okay.
He I've never seen someone who would more be in a Sprite commercial than Jason
Derulo. Like not in the Coke commercial, you know?
Well, okay. They want me to do Sprite. Sure. Wiggle wiggle with it,
bro.
How are you gonna make a song about a big fat butt Beatles,
Beatles. Rolling over in the grip. Beatles songs. suck too though. You know,
beautiful songs. they're just like.
We live in a yellow submarine. All right, dude.
Ah, people love the Beatles bro. And they're just like.
See in the sky we've done months and people are like, Oh,
but it's about LSD. Oh really? Oh yeah. Uh,
okay.
John Lennon is the though. That imagined song.
I mean it's disrespectful, but John Lennon is the.
I remember when I was a kid,
I saw a movie called backbeat about the Beatles with my parents.
And Ringo was only in like two scenes. And after the movie, I said to my dad,
I said, Hey, imagine you were in you, you,
you were an actor and you got the part of Ringo and you're like, Hey guys,
I'm going to be in a movie about the Beatles. And I play Ringo.
People will be like so like excited. And then you're only in two scenes.
And then my dad and it made me feel.
So good. And because I love to make my parents laugh all the time.
And that's probably what made me why I'm a comedian. Uh,
so here we go. Ads. We go wiggle with it.
Do to rail. Jason Derulo is in cats,
bro. You understand what I'm saying? Let's look up this, cats, the movie.
First of all, don't make cats, the movie. And lemme tell you why? Because cats,
the musical sucks. That's why. Oh really
Perrigo. Heck what is the thing? Parago. Hats. What the do they?
Jellicoe genetical cats. Oh yeah. See ya. Oh really?
Jellicoe cats. See ya. Oh,
are you on Lucy in the sky with diamonds? When you wrote this,
see ya dude. Gelical cats. You understand what I'm saying?
And Jason Derulo was like, yup.
Are you out of your mind world?
Jason Derulo said, Jellicoe cats.
Sign me up. We put boop, boop, boop, boop. Hey dude.
That whole thing is utter nonsense.
Imagine going to see a matinee of cats.
Dude, stay in the car.
If you drive to Katz for a matinee,
stay in the parking lot in the car and just make up in your head.
It'll be way better, dude. I would never see that movie.
cats, dude. They try to make it all like
hoo cats and then what's her name? Just like on the
with her human nails and. What's her name?
Taylor Swift bro. You know,
focus on getting your catalog back. on getting your catalog back.
Don't make a movie. What are you doing? Tell her.
Swift.
Focusing on getting your Cadillac back from scooter. Braun, scooter Braun.
How scooter Braun. Not in the 1940s.
Hey, what's up? How you doing? I'd like to manage it. My name's Skoda.
Go to Bron. Hey, how are ya? He has a hat.
He'd have a hat with like one of those feathers in it. Hey, how you doing kiddo?
Yeah, you look really talented. How old are you Warren at the poopy? Well,
you got to grow up to be a superstar.
I'm just good. It's good abroad.
Would you like to go see a matinee? What is it?
It's a bunch of cats running around, absolutely ridiculous.
You'd rather stay in a car. Come on. Let's go get some popcorn and lollipops.
Let's go. You're gonna be a big star one day when in years,
because that's when you'll grow up. You're so young.
Yeah, negative 40. Did you come in how it was? Just walks up to a pregnant lady.
Hello? Now I can tell you. Yes. I'm going to be a big star. What?
Hey, you pregnant? All right. Yeah. Yeah. Sounds got talent.
I don't even know if it's a boy or a girl yet. Shut the up. You stupid.
Let's go. That's good, Ron. Uh,
yeah dude. Wow. I can't wait to see cats.
I would never see cats do it. I would never.
Cats dude of, Oh the,
the people that are in it are so I've never been a more asset.
Of course cast in my life.
I cannot believe that people in cats let's just roll down the people in cats.
Okay.
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift is playing bum Bula arena.
See ya. The name SIG dude, the names.
Aye.
Dude. Okay. Let me tell you something. Of course.
If Hollywood asked me to be in cats, I would be in cats. Do you know why?
Because I want to be in cats. However, right under that.
If my agent.
If my manager, Josh Lieberman called me and it was like, okay,
there's morning cat. All right. There's running cats. Okay.
First of all, the way Josh has cats is definitely spelled K I T Z online cat
cats. All right. And then you're doing that.
Me just give me Judy J quarter kind of Swift vehicle. Okay. And it's like,
they have a pur in there and they want you to plant. It's like stand comedian,
cat. You know, he doesn't understand it. And the joke is the part is rum.
Tum Tilly, Tom, you know?
Well, the role is rum tum until Tom is on page 75. You're looking at,
I don't want to go. And but okay. Anyway, um,
uh, and uh, and I would be in it, but dude, I would, I would be like, Hey Josh,
call Hollywood back. Not being in cats, but I would be in cats. Anyway.
Taylor Swift is a Bumble arena. Shaya, L S D.
Okay.
Jennifer Hudson is in it like of course you could guess this cast and she plays
Griz. Abella Hey, just call these cats. Lisa in.
James cordon plays,
what is the name here? It won't, it won't show bust differ.
Uh, uh, uh, transformer.
What's the name?
Plus defer Jones dude, dude,
that is such a song.
That would be by F what's that what's that group what's that is Adam directs.
What's that group crown crows would make a song called Buster for Jones, dude.
Hi. You remember? But what's that long December. Yeah.
That's I said he would be like a what's the one more night in Hollywood where
you met Buster for Jon Jones.
That's Mr. That's Busta for Jon Jones
and it's called outside.
Um, you just elbows in it. That's the only one to me that is like,
doesn't make much sense in this movie. [inaudible] eh.
Mm.
Okay.
The next two are the S so much people that
would be in the movie cats.
They would literally like a real talking cat would get over.
They would, it'd be like, well, that's between you and a real talking cat.
And they'd be like,
and you got it because of course you're going to be in this movie because it's
you okay. A real talking cat will be like,
but I'm a real talking cat. And they'd be like, sorry,
gotta give it to Judi Dench. Dude.
Judy Dench is in cats course. And Ian McKellen there.
Rebel Wilson course.
And then I'm sorry, but the one that makes the most sense is Jason to reload.
Yeah.
It's just so funny to me that Jason Derulo is in a movie cats
that I'm going to rip my Dick off. I mean, dude,
Jason Derulo. Imagine Jason,
I cannot wait to look up red carpet,
pictures of Jason Derulo at the movie at the cats. Premiere.
I cannot wait to see the, for real horse he's wearing.
Dude.
And I'd be like, what are you doing? I'm just wiggling with it.
Dude. Like it when's it come out, dude.
I've talked about cats in this thing. It comes out soon, right?
It's a good time for sure. Christmas movie.
Is this more for kids, dude? It's so creepy. If I was a kid,
this is how I'd be like when my mom said, Hey, you want to go see cats?
I go like this, know what? W w it's for kids. I go like this.
Now why to kill.
To Kelly.
You don't want to go in. No, I'll stay in the car. You go see it.
It's too Kelly. I'll stay in the stroller.
You go in there always to carry. But Jason Derulo is in it.
That's tick Nicholas, but Judy Dench is in it.
Of course she is James Corden plays Busta for Jones. Dusk
does counting crows song. Jennifer Hudson's in it.
Does she play Gracelle but that makes sense. Taylor Swift is in it.
Burn ballerina curse. And they're going to go to see stupid Gelica CAS,
negotiates, Angelica CAS. You made me go see the music or I hate that.
Desper that's read in four.
That was wrote in the people who wrote down was on Dallas D
and then 1980s, the poop it,
um, let's look at the cat's trailer, dude. I know we've seen it,
but we got to see it again. Dude. Wiggle, wiggle with it. Meow, Meow, Meow,
Meow, Meow cats movie.
No,
I'd rather stay in the car and put my pants and just have a shutter diaper for
two hours. But no buts,
say how fun, but it's a universal pick.
They make good movies, but this one's a weird one.
I'm sorry, dude. The cat's got a top hat I'm out. I can't. I mean,
talk about, gelical
talk about gelical.
I cannot believe that Jason dural is in this movie,
dude. I swear to God at the end of this movie, the cat goes no. And he goes,
what's that in your cat pocket and pulls out a Sprite. And he goes,
[inaudible] wiggle, wiggle with it.
So beautiful.
Oh wow. There's a thing in the back of his milk bar.
I haven't seen before. Cause you're a human cat.
Little they're little for a new life.
That's me. Twirling cats
in a room. That's so ornate.
They've got ears that are on top of their heads,
but also somehow it's not uncomfortable for them to wear hats.
James Courtney, of course. And Judy Dench, of course.
And also of course, Jason Derulo, drinking spray, Idris Elba. For some reason,
Jennifer Hudson.
Remember her Ian McKellen is naturally Taylor
Swift vehicle
and rebel Wilson does stuff like falls down and stuff.
Does it say, does it have the nerve to say introducing someone? No.
No, no. That's a joke, right? That didn't say that. Did it. Oh
bro. It's introducing some,
it's introducing an actor, bro. I haven't seen that in years, dude.
I haven't seen that since like a Sundance movie.
And when Sundance first came and introducing ed burns dude and this
movie cats is get the nerve. Oh my God girl.
Introducing Francesca Hayward, dude. I'm sorry.
I'm actually left so hard on my throat. I'm not even joking.
Bro.
Introducing Francesca Hayward. And then it shows her.
Mostly a cat.
Just say introducing another cat.
That's like that's like when they do Johnny Depp in rank ago and
you're like, he's just, it's a cartoon lizard. You Johnny.
Depp's not in it. That's a lizard with a suitcase
Dude. That drives me nuts when they do that.
When it's like a cartoon and they're like
dude. Oh for sake man.
And introducing. Oh actually, nevermind. It's a fun.
Can cat
director of limb Miserables and the King speech. All that will be wrapped.
What's his name? Colin Firth.
When he's just like, [inaudible].
Move your rift. When that guy didn't he win the Oscar for that, bro.
You won the Oscar for that closeup when he was like.
Uh.
Bro. If I was in that movie. Oh. I would've killed that.
Reading the thing.
Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye bro,
that movie ripped this director is good.
Shut up. You're in cell butters.
Look at this.
What it just said. I don't even know. And from Andy blank and boob,
they're making up bro, bro. What's happening.
Dude.
And from Andy blank and Buehler choreograph, choreographer of Hamilton,
dude, you made that up. You made that name up, dude. You,
you know why you made it up because the names of the cats are so wacky that
we're like, yeah. They're like it's it's Andy blank. It's Andy blank.
And they're like, it's going to look weird in the credits.
It make it a different thing.
And some guy was just like Andy Blankenbuehler and they're like, yeah,
it looks nice. Weird, dude. It looks weird.
James Corden is playing bus top McHenry
James James Henry is playing bus. Stop Magoo. A Gouda Cali dude,
the late night host playing bus, stop Jones. We got it.
He can't be any blank.
Andrew Lloyd Webber.
And Ts Eliot.
Idris Elba.
They have hats on for different life.
Look at that. That's the best that line.
The next line that cut it. But the next time, the next.
The next line they cut it. But the next line is.
Are you going to try for a different life? A course. I am.
I'm a smoke cat. I'm a,
a hound. That was the next line. They cut it for the
[inaudible] to try for different life. Cops were up song.
I got
[inaudible] right here. Right here. Right here.
Come on. You going to try for a different life.
A mama
one Jew
trailers always go quiet right before they end.
It'll be like
[inaudible] and then it'll go
cat cat. This holiday season.
You'll believe
booboo bro, uh.
Goran bros.
Goran bros sent me some hats there bro.
Send me a Dickel. These guys sent me a like a cap,
a cap bro. Butters. What the was that?
What is just when Matt butters come here.
Come here. Where are you? Okay, come here buddy. Good boy.
Good boy. Doing what I say always good boy. Just
anyway.
Um, anyway, they sent me a th the, the,
uh, baseball hat and it, and it,
it has a Wiener dog on it.
And bro, I wouldn't want to decal a whole episode. You understand me?
I wouldn't wanna Charlie goodnight. The whole episode,
my scooter Braun pressure wouldn't have even been better. Hey, how's it going?
I'm scooter Braun. Your kids is superstar. What are you talking about?
My kid I'm eight. Yeah,
but you're going to grow up and you're going to get pregnant and then you're
going to have a kid and I can tell he's a superstar already.
What you're going to do. I'm going to buss drums on him and he's to
Make up, give them two sticks in a pan in a Stan
Bron. Um,
every time I talk about somebody that I get in trouble, they'll write back like,
Oh yeah. We heard about the Gorumboro scooter. Braun is gonna tweet me now.
Um.
Hm.
Dude. I'm sorry, but cats bro. Oh, wow.
They talked about it on an H three. The cats movie trailers, a nightmare.
They say, you know, what's weird is sometimes they don't have the, uh,
what do you call it? The um,
th the CGI all done until the movie.
Like they won't have it done on the trailer and they will have it done in the
movie. So maybe that's what's up, but universal pictures, you know, they come,
somebody wrote on the comments under it.
This is what the people in the bird box saw before they die. That's hilarious.
Mammary. He's nothing more than memory.
He's got some memory.
He's we've got memories for [inaudible].
How many memory he's would you like to
[inaudible] memories are about nine 50, but if you'll get two,
we'll give you a
[inaudible] three for two ma'am
you can buy a dozen and we'll charge you for dad,
mammaries whatever.
In the middle of cats, it went off the rails and that's the song that happened.
You understand how that would be my favorite movie. Do you understand?
You don't do it. You don't and they'll just keep making the same,
grow some balls and bastardized some, man.
I'll never be in another movie again after this podcast, but you know,
maybe Netflix, Netflix seems to employ your boy.
I might do this movie in January. I'm not sure yet.
And I told him to write more off scenes in them in it. And they were like,
you got it.
And they sent me the signs and I'm ripping through the jungle with my shirts
off.
[Inaudible].
Do it. I just want to be in a movie where I'm just like.